Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
continuing where we left off last week
with respect to
the chains, the yolks,
the imprisonment
that
our prophet sallall.aii Wasam was sent
by Allah to us in order to release us
from
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam to us. He
says the messenger of Allah, the
prophet, the unlettered prophet whom
they find his description
drawn out at great length in detail
in the previous books in the Torah that
was given to MS in the inj that was
given to Isa.
What are his most prominent traits?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says he
commands them with good
and prohibits them from evil
and makes lawful for them that which is
good and makes unlawful for them that
which is
bad and lowly and filthy and that
which is undignified.
And then he says, "And he relieves them
from the yolks and chains that they were
in prior to his coming saiam.
Humanity was in yolks and chains.
Humanity
was
in utter chaos and utter darkness
before our prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
The prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam said
[Silence]
He said, "Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
looked upon the people of the earth in
the time of Jahia just prior to our
prophet being sent
and he
positively disdained
all of them except for a few pockets of
the people of the look here and there.
And so he sent to us this messenger in
that darkness.
The light that he was sent with, the
light of the Quran and Revelation and
the Sunnah, it pierced that darkness
and it relieved us of the chains and
yolks that we were in prior.
The chains and yolks that we were in
prior.
Humanity was in bondage to a shanim.
What were the chains and yolks?
The chains and yolks. The
chaos of Jahya.
The chaos of the
laws of Jahya which were incredibly
oppressive.
The superstitions
that humanity
was adhering to.
These superstitions are part of the
bondage,
the slavery that aanime
had placed humanity in.
People were afraid.
They were afraid
of certain movements. They were afraid
of certain days. They were afraid of
certain hours. They were afraid of
certain animals.
Not a natural fear, but a s but a
superstitious unnatural fear.
A fear
of
jin and
they were in fear of
witches.
They were in fear of their idols. They
were in fear of the servants of their
idols. It was chaos.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then sent
our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
and he
sent him to humanity to release them
from their bondage. And this is a point
that a shaitan
always
tries to manipulate people with
and try to convince people and hinder
them and deter them from adhering to the
prophets and messengers throughout time
with the notion that if you believe if
you become Muslim if you accept this
prophet or messenger you're not going to
be able to do what you want to do. It's
going to make your life worse. It's
going to make your life uncomfortable.
You're not going to be free. You're
going to be
a slave to this messenger
to the rules and regulations of that
religion. This is the ideal.
However, in reality,
people were in chains and yolks before
the messenger, not after. The messenger
came to release us from those chains and
yolks to truly
free
humanity.
No matter what, we were created as
slaves. slaves to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
We were not created into paradise.
Eat from whatever you want to eat, drink
from whatever you want to drink, do
whatever whim
whatever whim flashes through your
mind or heart. That is not the nature of
our existence here on this earth. Here
there are things which are detrimental
to us and there are things which are
beneficial. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam all prophets and messengers
they did not come in with that which
would inhibit humanity.
They came with that which would free and
emancipate humanity. free us and
emancipate us from anything
other than Allah and from anyone other
than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
as
it is said
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has sent us in
order to emancipate
the servants of Allah from the slaves of
Allah. Emancipate them from the slavery
to other slaves of Allah
and make them true slaves only to Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
This is what the prophets and messengers
were sent with.
There is no chains and yolks that come
with
following the Quran and Sunnah.
The only thing that a person is
prohibited from doing is that which is
detrimental to him. That which will
enslave him, that which will ensnare
him.
However,
anything that is healthy, that is good,
that is righteous, that is clean,
none of that is prohibited, especially
in the legislation of Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam.
And so one of those things is
the superstitions that they dealt with
in Jahyah.
Our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
says in the narration of
collected by both bkari and Muslim. He
said
here
he is negating many of the beliefs that
were common place in Jah.
So he says subhanahu wa'ta'ala
he says saiam
he tells us
there is no superstitions there are no
bad omens that a person can receive.
If a bird flies off and it goes to the
right then you're going to have a good
day. If it goes to the left you're going
to have a bad day. If a black cat
crosses your path, wow, you you're just
you're done. You're doomed, right? If
you get onto the plane and they sit you
in row number 13, it's terrible. What
what are you going to do? How can you
escape such a devastating fate, right?
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
this is a figment of people's
imagination.
just doesn't exist.
This does not exist. There are no
superstitious numbers. There are no
superstitious days. There are no
superstitious dates. There are no
superstitious places.
There is good and bad. There is rational
and irrational.
He then says,
"Alham
is a belief that they had in Jahya and
it still managed to stick around to this
day.
And that is the superstitions attached
to the owl.
The owl, the animal, the bird, right?
What is the superstitions of the owl?
that if a super that if an owl comes and
lands on top of your house and makes a
noise at night, someone in that house is
going to die,
right?
And they also believed that if someone
were to be murdered, they would say
murdered before his time. This actually
I am young enough or old enough you
could say to remember this. I'm sure all
of us have some some version of these.
But we were told that if a person dies
young, if a person is killed as a young
man, let's say,
then he actually had
another few decades to live. But he was
murdered early.
So what happens now is his soul will go
into an owl or it will take the the form
of an owl and it will circle
and it will continue to roam about until
vengeance is taken on his behalf in
order to release his soul.
And we still have that belief here even
in America.
You look at any story of haunting.
Haunting. Someone goes actually you know
someone buys a house then they start
saying well we're having trouble. We
believe the house is haunted. What's the
first thing that will happen? that will
go and look at the history of the house
and say, "Wow,
this man was here and he actually was
killed in this house." And I believe
that's his soul roaming around in the
house, still unable to transition to the
afterlife. As if Allah created the soul
to just roam around in a house all day
and give new homeowners the willies. He
doesn't have anything new to do. He
doesn't have to go to the grave. He
doesn't have to go to paradise or hell.
No, he was created to take the form of
an old man and scare little girls in
their bed. This
is exactly the superstitions that that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
negated.
There are there are jin they do play
games. But when a person dies, his soul
is detached from his body in a permanent
way
and he is placed into a reality that is
known as alzak,
the grave,
whether his body is in a grave or not.
and therein he will endure either
punishment or pleasure based on what
kind of person he was until the day of
judgment when Allah will resurrect the
souls and reattach them to their
rightful bodies.
We will continue this inshall next week
and
subhanahuaala
[Silence]
You
And
Allah
will act.
I shall be
in
[Silence]
I shall
All
[Silence]
I saw. Oh,
hallelujah. Hello.
Allah
Love.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Muslim. Simon.
[Silence]
foram.
them.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that everything
every creation
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has created it
with a destiny
with a carved out.
It has its limitations.
It has its purpose. It has its destiny
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has told us of this book of destiny.
He says subhanahua
that all
of the creation's destiny and and decree
is found in the preserved tablets of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
subala.
for
[Silence]
he says subhanahua that he has created
the heavens and the earth and all that
is in between.
Number one, for a reason, for a purpose,
and number two,
with a named and determined
time of expiration.
This is so important for us
to
not just
believe on a surface level.
We have to take this belief in the
decree of Allah
to the deepest parts of our conviction
and believe truly with every fiber of
our being
that everything on this earth
has been created for a purpose
and everything
has a determined determined time
to fulfill that purpose
that when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
creates something the time for that
being that thing its existence its
expiry has been named and documented by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala at the moment
of creation
it has already been written
our Prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us in the narration of Abdullahb.
He says, "Sallam
[Silence]
He says sai wasallam There is not one of
you, no human being, none of us
outside of Adam
and these are the two only exceptions.
Every human being
will remain in his mother's womb for 40
days as a drop.
And that drop then grows into
a small clinging clot for 40 more days.
And then after 40 more days,
120 days, it will grow and develop into
a small lump of flesh.
And at the 120day mark,
the angel is then sent to this fetus
and commanded by Allah to put the soul
into this new creation of Allah.
And four things are documented at that
moment.
The first is this individual's
time on this earth.
Exactly when his expiry will be, the
exact time, the exact date.
The second
is this person's deeds.
Will they be good? Will they be bad?
The third to write
whether this creation of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala what sustenance and risk this
person will have
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's risk
and the fourth whether this person
ultimately is
is a person of damnation
a a person of eternal bliss.
Will he be amongst the miserable or the
blissful?
Will he be of the people of paradise or
the hellfire? Ultimately,
every one of us
has had these four things written at the
moment that his soul was married to his
body.
Every one of us,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has created
everything
with a decree.
Now, this doesn't mean that we do not
have
free will.
We do. We have free will which makes us
incredibly unique
as far as creatures are concerned.
There are only three creatures
of this creation that have this free
will. The human being, the jin and the
angels. Aside from that, free will has
been reserved.
But this free will
is all part of the knowledge of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is not
learning new things from his creation.
He did not create us and then learn from
us.
He subhanahu wa ta'ala
knows knew all that was, all that is,
all that is to be, all that would have
been, had things been.
And he subhanahu wa ta'ala
wrote what is to be in the preserved
tablet.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us
that a group of the companions asked
they came to ask him
we came to ask you oh messenger of Allah
about the first thing that Allah created
in this world.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said
[Silence]
that the first thing Allah created of
this creation is the pen. And he said to
it, "Write."
It responded, "What shall I write?" He
said, "Write all that is to be until the
day of judgment."
And so all of this was written.
Every word I will ever utter, every beat
of your heart, every breath you have
ever been allotted by Allah,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala knew and knows
all of that and wrote it in the
preserved tablet.
And he subhanahu wa ta'ala willed for
that to be.
Allah tells us you all do not will for
something to be except that Allah has
willed
and allowed that thing to be.
And then he subhanahu wa ta'ala created
all that is created.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has no other
creators with him.
This is the breakdown that our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam gives us of the
decree and destiny of Allah.
See, two different groups of people
have emerged throughout history with
respect to the topic of destiny and free
will.
You've got a group that are so extreme
in their belief in destiny
that
they
do not believe in the free will that the
human being has.
That essentially we are being forced by
way of decree and destiny to make the
decisions and choices that we have.
And this as well is the viewpoint of
many in the world of modern science.
The idea is that we are nothing but
biology.
We are nothing but chemicals
and reactions.
We are nothing but neurons firing in
your brain. And we make decisions based
on that.
There is no free will beyond that just
animals.
Then there is another group that is so
extreme in the opposite
that they do not believe in destiny at
all.
That they believe that
the human being has so much free will
that there is no such thing as destiny
and nothing has been written by Allah.
Then there are the followers of the
prophets and messengers.
Those who believe in free will
and believe in destiny.
Does that mean that every Muslim will
understand every intricate detail of
free will and destiny? Absolutely not.
However, we know of these two topics
enough to worship Allah adequately.
We know of these two things enough
through the Quran and the Sunnah
that we are able to move on from the
past
and we as well
are expected to take responsibility for
the choices that we make.
The prophet sallall.aii
am.
He tells us
that anything that afflicts you was
written.
It was never meant to miss you.
And anything that misses you was never
meant to afflict you.
He taught this to even the children in
Medina.
He tells us that our prophet Sam
told him once
[Silence]
he said I am going to teach you some
truisms,
some proverbs,
some sentences of wisdom to live your
life by
preserve Allah's laws.
Preserve and mind Allah's boundaries and
he will preserve you.
Build a relationship with Allah
and get to know Allah in your times of
ease
and he will recognize you and he will be
there for you in your times of
difficulty.
He says sam
[Silence]
He says, Wasam
know
that
if all of humanity were to collaborate
to attempt to benefit you with
something, they would only be able to
benefit you with that which Allah has
already written for you.
And if all of humanity were to
collaborate,
to attempt to harm you with something,
they will only be able to harm you with
that which Allah has already written
upon you.
The pens of decree have already been
lifted off of the pages
and those pages have already dried.
He says saiam
that know that that which misses you was
never meant to be for you
and that which is for you was never
meant to miss you.
This is the precision of the decree of
Allah.
And so the question then comes we have
largely heard this before.
Many of us have already heard these
narrations. We've heard this in the
Quran. But how do we apply this to our
lives? How can we strike that balance
between
taking accountability
but not fretting over that which is out
of our control?
How do we walk that middle path between
free will and destiny?
Our prophet sallall.aii wasallam teaches
us
a way a method of life
that if you follow this formula
you will never take on
grief.
guilt that does not belong to you.
And if you follow this formula,
you will never
chalk something up to being of the
decree of Allah
when there is a level of accountability
to be had on your behalf.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said
as Abu narrates to us in Muslim.
He says
he said
a strong believer in his belief is
better is superior and more beloved to
Allah than a weak believer in his
belief.
But in both there is good.
He says
he says seek out anything that will
benefit you that will benefit you.
Seek out ANYTHING THAT WILL BENEFIT you
and seek aid in Allah and do not give
up.
[Silence]
He says, "Seek constantly that which is
good for you either in this life or the
hereafter.
Seek aid in Allah in your journey and do
not give up.
And do not look at something that has
already happened that's already dead and
gone
and say if only I have done had done
such and such the result would have been
different.
Rather say that is the decree of Allah
and what he has willed he has done.
Because if only in this context will
only work to open upon the human being
the actions of a shaitan.
Now what does this mean? this this
narration he tells us with respect to
the future
constantly seek out the best
result
in anything you want something to be in
your future in your present work hard
for it and seek aid in Allah and make
dua and struggle and strive to obtain
it.
However, when you are afflicted with
something,
when something happens to you, when the
decree of Allah
presents you with something that you
were not expecting,
something that is less than favorable.
Do not look to the past and say, "If
only I had done such and such, the
result would have been different."
rather say that is the decree of Allah
and what he has decided and decreed and
destined that is what happened.
Notice the wording here
that a person looks back at the past and
doesn't say if I had done things would
have been different.
Who are you? Who am I? Who is any human
being to make the bold claim
that he with his little hands and his
little mind and his little choices can
reach up into the heavens and change
what Allah has written in the his
preserved tablet. If only I had done
such and such, the past would have been
different. No,
there is no one here that can lay claim
to being able to alter what Allah has
penned in that preserved tablet.
We have a destiny and we know that
something is in the preserved tablet
once it happens.
And so we don't look back at spilled
milk and say, "Well, if only I had
done." All that does is cause you to
carry grief in your heart that doesn't
belong to you. That will at least weaken
you in your future resolve.
[Arabic recitation]
Allahight
Lord.
I shall
[Silence]
Allahbar
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps.
Straightening of the rows and standing
as coherently and straight as possible.
Each person aligning his shoulders and
feet with the shoulders and feet of his
two neighbors. This is of paramount
importance and it is one of the things
that our prayer will be judged and
rewarded based on.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
amen.
Fore!
[Silence]
Foreign! Foreign!
for
[Silence]
Allah.
Allahbel
[Silence]
Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
Holy.
Amen.
[Silence]
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
Allah
Allahbel
[Silence]
All
long.
[Silence]
All
the
[Silence]
My dear brothers and sisters, assalamu
alaykum.
Just have a couple of reminders.
First is today after Murab there will
be a gathering at U I imabuhanifa mosque
and there are a couple of things on the
agenda there. First is a commemoration
of the Isra
and then also there is a farewell to
brother Hassan from the community
perspective and there will be
there is a dinner that's going to be
served there inshallah. So if you are
able to make it that will be great
opportunity. the second is Muslim
Youth of America
is holding a fundraising dinner tomorrow
inshallah after MGH and that is being
chaired by Dr. Naser Maha and also
Imam Imam Hassan is also part of that.
So that's going to be tomorrow after mab
inshallah. And the purpose of that is to
raise some funds for the Muslim youth of
America for their activities. Inshallah.
There's a $20 fee to get in, but
inshallah you'll enjoy that. also the
last thing I want to mention is now it's
the new year. Alhamdulillah.
We have to work hard to redirect our
state tax liability
to the benefit of Rahma Academy. So I
want to make sure you understand my
words properly. It's not going to cost
you anything. You're going to simply
redirect the liability